how um for you uh obviously coming from
your culture I always would hear that
there'd be like arranged marriages right
yes that's a real thing 100 my parents
now it's a very fluid thing now now you
your parents might be like hey our
family knows this person you guys will
date for a while and then be like so
it's more like a setup right but there
are arranged marriages my dad didn't
know he was getting married till his
wedding day she was so he didn't know
who he was marrying not only did he not
know who he was marrying he didn't know
he was getting married period until his
wedding day how old was he when he
married your mom 24. what the [ __ ] so
how does so so give me that their story
even uncles and aunties that hear it are
like that's bananas like imagine you
don't know you're getting married and
then he was at another wedding yeah and
his cousins came up and they were like
you tell him you tell him he's like
somebody tell me and they said you're
getting married today so he's in the car
going over there getting fitted for a
suit
taking measurements because my mom was
in America at the time she went to
America when she was she didn't know her
real age but they listed it breaking and
then she was there for like a finite
amount of time and my dad's family not
even a media family but like they
thought immediate family because
actually his uncle was like high up in
the Indian government so my mom's family
was like this is great he's from a good
family these guys are set up and then my
dad's family was like she's a pretty
girl she's in America this is great same
cast same everything right let's just
get it done what's a cast
in Hinduism now I don't know if this is
implemented by the I should research
more I've heard is implemented by the
Brits I've heard it's not but in
Hinduism there are casts okay and it's
like a class of people kind of it is
classist but my understanding was always
that it is supposed to be more like an
assembly line than a class system more
like hey you guys are focused on this
thing you guys are focused on my cast
ironically because I'm so small as the
warrior cast Okay because like look
y'all if we go to war y'all uh [ __ ]
there that's what you're worried about
right if you're the labor cast you are
working that's what you're working on
can you ever upgrade cast which is
that's but again if it's not done in a
classist way right no big deal right but
but it kind of It kind of has to be I
mean it you know yeah but it's gonna
humans are gonna do that now again I've
my wife was telling me she wrote a book
my wife's not Hindu she's a seek sick
okay but uh she was saying she read
another book where they're like no
that's very much baked in the Hinduism I
didn't pick that up I need to read a
little better uh but yeah the idea was
just like hey this is the most efficient
lady yeah like if you're in the working
class it's like
you you just know that this is your life
like yeah there should be someone else
I'm gonna be honest if I'm born and you
look at me and I'm 15 years old and I'm
5'2 and 160 pounds or whatever I was
back then you gotta be like this ain't
no Warrior okay
do something else okay
this guy Merchant class he could he's
good with money yeah you know I mean
there should have been but again this
was uh this is the oldest religion so
it's
four thousand years ago five thousand
years ago we're talking so did your mom
know she was getting married she knew it
was a possible so she knew it might
happen she met the family yeah and she
was like okay but it wasn't that much
say in it what the [ __ ] I mean she could
have said no so was it like your dad's
parents decision to be like you're
getting married today like who who makes
the call I think my dad's parents or
maybe my dad's uncle again who's like
the more like um like the patriarch
right uh but yeah I don't know exactly
who decided he doesn't I don't even know
he didn't even care who decided and your
parents love each other
[Laughter]
I will say I have seen it's just like
the the rates are the same as what we
call love marriages okay where it seems
like half the couples I see that
arranged they're like they're really in
love they make it work it's a beautiful
thing and then the other half is like oh
this never should have happened this is
like a business relationship yeah or
just you guys aren't even yeah there's
some rough ones yeah the husband is a
monster whatever though you know but at
the same time you look at American
marriage this is a 52 divorce rate or
whatever yeah it's 50 50. what I feel
like I've learned I don't want to be
arrogant to act like I have the keys to
marriage and Fidelity and all of that
but what I think I've learned is if both
of y'all are willing to do the work
because you will make it that seems like
what it yeah and I think I think that's
what most people they give up when
things get [ __ ] you know what I mean
yeah when they get rough when you hit a
rough spot it's like most people just
give up or they cheat or they you you
know they pull the plug a little early
irreconcilable differences is the thing
that we always just say but like how
many differences are really irrational
yeah like he he hits you right he
assaults you in any way he is abusive in
any way or maybe maybe he cheats
she cheats that's irreconcilable He
Cheats I feel like yeah I mean we can
reconcile this of course it's a lot more
intimate when a woman cheats like you
got a guy inside of you right yeah it's
definitely a sexist approach but it's
true how dare you dude yeah yeah
definitely I agree with you man yeah
dude yeah for sure ladies come on be
decent you know